l'art contemporain est-il nul c'est pas
moi qui pose la question c'est Jean
Baudrillard le Meetic penseur de la
société de consommation et du film
Matrix il pose cette question dans le
quotidien Libération en novembre 1996 et
dans l'heure qui suit le tout pari de
l'art est en ébullition la polémique du
race bon moi au cours desquels les
partisans de l'art contemporain
assimileront parfois les détracteurs à
des fascistes Jean Baudrillard a
déclenché un des plus violents
affrontements idéologiques sur l'art
contemporain faut dire qu'il n'y va pas
demain morte je les cite l'art
contemporain spécule sur la culpabilité
de ceux qui n'y comprennent rien ou qui
n'ont pas compris qu'il n'y avait rien à
comprendre
[Musique]
avec le recul la polémique est créée par
Jean Baudrillard semble appartenir à la
tradition française du débat sur l'art
qui remonte au moins à la querelle des
anciens et des modernes de la fin du 17e
siècle mais la polémique est aussi
révélatrice d'un malaise en effet
beaucoup de gens y compris parmi les
initiés du monde de la culture pensent
comme Baudrillard qu'il y a un problème
fondamental avec ce qu'on appelle l'art
contemporain c'est à dire l'air de
l'histoire de l'art occidentale qu'on
fait conventionnellement commencer après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale même si
l'esprit de l'art contemporain est déjà
présent dans certaines œuvres chez
certains artistes et certains mouvements
du début du 20e siècle alors je suis pas
moi-même un expert de l'art contemporain
mais je m'y intéresse depuis pas mal
d'années et j'ai beaucoup lu sur le
sujet cette année pour créer la vidéo
sur l'art contemporain de mon programme
de culture générale culture express pour
vous aider à comprendre les critiques
des détracteurs je vais vous présenter
les trois arguments les plus forts
contre l'art contemporain écoutez moi
attentivement jusqu'au bout et vous
pourrez critiquer l'art contemporain
sans passer pour un beauf
si vous vous êtes baladé place Vendôme
une déplace les plus luxueuses au monde
au centre de Paris si vous vous y êtes
baladé à la mi-octobre 2014 vous avez pu
apercevoir ça c'est une œuvre d'art
contemporain du plasticien américain de
Los Angeles Paul McCarthy il a intitulé
tree mais il avoue que ce n'est pas un
arbre qu'il pensait au départ je le cite
tout est parti d'une plaisanterie à
l'origine je trouvais que le plug anal
avait une forme similaire aux sculptures
de brinkusi un sculpteur important du
début du 20e siècle après je me suis
rendu compte que cela ressemblait à un
arbre de Noël donc nous avons bien
affaire à un SexToy Géant quel est le
problème le problème ce n'est pas que
les sextoys c'est mal le problème c'est
que la création semble essentiellement
motivée par la transgression le but de
l'artiste et de choquer la morale
sociale afin de capter l'attention de
l'opinion publique et ainsi décupler sa
notoriété et cela a fonctionné le plug
géant scandalisé une partie de la
population il a été vandalisé en même
temps ce n'est pas très difficile vu que
c'est une sculpture gonflable l'AR
encore affaiblir l’argument en
considérant que la transgression est un
ingrédient de leur occidental grosso
modo depuis le 19e siècle oui mais
attendez l'argument suivant
100 millions de dollars 100 millions de
dollars c'était le prix de vente en 2007
de ce crâne sculpté par Damian Hearts
l'artiste britannique le plus célèbre de
l'art contemporain il a intitulé cette
création forve love of God pour l'amour
de Dieu en français c'est une réplique
du véritable crâne d'un homme du 18e
siècle qui était mort grosso modo à mon
âge 100 millions de dollars pour ça
c'est énorme mais il faut prendre en
compte le fait que le crâne est incrusté
de 8601 diamants donc ça n'est pas une
arnaque à un tel prix on imagine bien
qu'il n'y aura pas la queue devant le
magasin c'est peut-être même trop cher
pour une seule personne c'est en effet
un groupe d'investisseurs qui a été le
premier acquéreur du crâne et parmi ces
investisseurs il y a Damian heartst
attendez c'est pas le nom de l'artiste
ou bien c'est un homonyme non non c'est
bien lui un artiste qui achète lui-même
sa propre œuvre qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette histoire en fait l'explication est
assez simple le crâne était si cher que
personne n'en voulait dans une telle
situation la loi de de la demande fait
baisser le prix jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un
soit intéressé à un prix plus bas
peut-être qu'à 10 millions c'était bon
mais voilà la baisse du prix ça ne fait
pas les affaires de Damien heart donc il
a lui-même acheté l'oeuvre bien sûr pas
pour mettre le crâne sur son bureau mais
dans l'espoir de le revendre plus cher
voici donc le deuxième argument contre
l'art contemporain l’œuvre est un objet
de spéculation certains critiques
compare même les oeuvres d'art
contemporain aux produits financiers à
l'origine de la crise de 2008 non
seulement de riches particuliers et des
fonds d'investissement achètent des
créations dans une optique purement
spéculative mais les artistes à l'instar
de Damien Hearts rentrent eux aussi dans
cette logique or le problème de cette
logique c'est qu'elle se moque de la
valeur d'usage de l'oeuvre dans les airs
précédentes de l'histoire de l'art
l'acheteur était la plupart du temps un
amateur qui avait l'intention d'embellir
son environnement visuel et de jouir de
l’œuvre au quotidien mais dans des
créations comme le crâne de Damien
hearth c'est la valeur d'échange qui est
importante ce n'est pas fait pour
regarder c'est fait pour acheter
et pour vendre après on peut relativiser
cet argument de la même manière que le
premier j'ai résonné à partir d'un
exemple extrême en réalité la plupart
des oeuvres d'art contemporain ont bien
une valeur d'usage puisque elles sont
exposées et la spéculation existe dans
le marché de l'art depuis qu'il existe
des gens riches et qui trouvent un
intérêt au création des artistes oui
mais le dernier argument c'est du lourd
ça c'est une oeuvre d'art je ne sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte mais ça c'est
un urinoir en porcelaine il a été
baptisé fontaine par Marcel Duchamp le
français qui est le grand précurseur de
l'art contemporain l'exposition new
yorkaise à laquelle il a proposé cette
oeuvre en 1917 la refusé mais l'urinoir
a ensuite connu un destin exceptionnel
jusqu'à devenir emblématique du 20e
siècle dans l'histoire de l'art bien sûr
le choix d'un urinoir est fait pour
choquer le bourgeois en jouant sur le
tabou des excréments on peut donc déjà
critiquer le projet avec le premier
argument de cette vidéo mais ce n'est
pas cela qui est révélateur par rapport
à l'art contemporain ce qui est
révélateur c'est que Marcel Duchamp crée
avec l'urinoir la mode des ready maids
prête à l'emploi en français le poète
André Breton le chef de fil du
surréalisme définit le ready made dans
son Dictionnaire abrégé du surréalisme
comme je cite un objet
usuel promu à la dignité d'objets d'art
par le simple choix de l'artiste si
c'est le simple choix de l'artiste qui
promeut un objet à la dignité alors la
valeur artistique déserte l'objet
lui-même c'est ça le troisième argument
la valeur artistique n'est plus
intrinsèque à l’œuvre mais extra sec ce
sont les autorités culturelles de
l'artiste des galeries des salons des
musées des commentateurs des critiques
etc ce sont ces autorités culturelles
qui disent qu'un urinoir est une œuvre
d'art et impose grâce à leur ascendant
cette idée étonnante au public en clair
le monde de l'art dit que telle chose
est de l'art donc la société considère
que c'est de l'art mais ce qui explique
plus fondamentalement le malaise du
public c'est qu'un leader ne manifeste
par définition aucune habilité
supérieure de la part de l'artiste
puisque c'est un objet tout fait or
l'habiliter supérieure de la part de
l'artiste c'est une dimension
essentielle de la définition
traditionnelle de l'art le mot art vient
d'ailleurs du latin ARS qui signifie
habileté savoir-faire dans l'émotion
esthétique ressentie de vente un tableau
de Léonard de Vinci par exemple il y a
en partie le respect de la compétence je
suis incapable de faire la la même chose
or cette composante disparaît totalement
de vente un ready made de Marcel Duchamp
sans le discours intellectuel qui
l'accompagne et le prestige des
autorités culturelles le spectateur ne
peut pas accorder spontanément une
valeur esthétique à une piste entière je
trouve ce dernier argument convaincant
mais on peut quand même y opposer un
autre argument l'art contemporain ne
peut pas être comparé aux aires
précédentes de l'histoire de l'art en
effet si l'art est fonction de l'état de
la civilisation alors là de la société
de consommation occidentale des 20e et
21e siècle ne peut pas être comparée aux
arts des sociétés antérieures car la
société de consommation occidentale des
20e et 21e siècle représente un état de
civilisation inédit à bien des égards
en résumé les trois arguments contre
l'art contemporain ce sont que les
artistes manipulent l'opinion publique
pour valoriser leurs œuvres que l'art
devient un prétexte pour faire de la
spéculation et enfin un plus
fondamentalement que les œuvres n'ont
plus de valeur artistique notamment
parce qu'elles ne sont plus le fruit
d'une habilité supérieure après il faut
aussi accepter de voir l'autre côté des
choses on peut relativiser chaque
argument comme je l'ai fait dans cette
vidéo voilà voilà j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu et puis qu'elle vous
sera utile si c'est le cas donnez-lui un
pouce bleu et puis laissez un
commentaire pour améliorer le
référencement de la vidéo ce n’est pas
grand chose et ça m'aide vraiment je
suis romain j'étais avec mon fidèle
Aristote et vous vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale rappelez-vous
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour vous intéresser aux
meilleurs de la pensée j'ai une question
à vous poser vous croyez vraiment que
les gens ont lu tous les livres dont ils
parlent bien sûr que non sinon on ne
pourrait pas parler de grand chose
et oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a 5 les étudiants et
les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
Ronan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'il les applique les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet il brille par leur
culture dans les conversations et dans
les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver dix fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo croyez-moi
faites-le et vous me remercierez